percent noble worth Al Gore excellencies
Friends of Planet bursts welcome to the
University of Oslo to the Nobel Peace
Prize for him and to the Oslo peace days
in 2015 the United Nations member states
adopted a 2030 agenda for sustainable
development including 17 sustainable
development goals the SDGs provides a
holistic and comprehensive framework for
development they are interconnected
intertwine and they requires that we
cooperate to solve it in the UN Agenda
it is stated that it will be for all of
us to ensure that the journey to
sustainable development is successful
all of us that means you and me my
friends we the question is of course how
when people or politicians ask me about
a return of its investment or the impact
of the University of Oslo
my response is clear it is our strong
research based education
it's our students after all we educate
the candidates that true history has
field and in future we'll fill the
positions in the big and responsible we
in order to succeed they must contribute
to society but with a skilled set of set
of skills and importantly a value set
that supports a sustainable planet the
key for a big way to succeed clearly
there are dilemmas with esta G's how do
we approach the trends the tension
between the goals how do we balance
economic Road and combating climate
change yesterday Danish McCrea get
connected new renewable energy
technology and human suffering resulting
from cobalt being mined in Congo
dilemmas problems challenges
that must be solved problems to be
solved by the big we the Nobel Peace
Prize forum is a collaboration between
the region Nobel Institute and
University of Oslo and it gives me great
pleasure to introduce the director of
the Nobel Institute dr. who love your
stuff
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen or as dr. Dennis McKay I said
it last yesterday
dear friends of peace when the Nobel
Peace Prize for 2007 was being announced
in October of that year the chair of the
Norwegian Nobel Committee the late
professor hula Dom Holt Muir's said
about today's keynote speaker
Mr Al Gore has for a long time been one
of the world's leading environmentalist
politicians his strong commitment
reflected in political activity lectures
films and books has strengthened the
struggle against climate change he is
probably the single individual who has
done most to create greater worldwide
understanding of the measures that need
to be adopted and professor Muir's went
on to say action is necessary now before
climate change moves beyond man's
control
ladies and gentlemen both statements
still hold true mr. gore is as forceful
and impatient as ever in his struggle to
save the environment but the climate
crisis remains unsolved global emissions
of carbon dioxide and other greenhouse
gases are as high as ever and may be
increasing again after a brief halt this
is why the organizers of this year's
Nobel Peace Prize for him had decided to
invite mr. Gore back to Oslo in order to
reflect upon three big questions after
all these years why haven't we achieved
more in turn
or solving the climate challenge is
there still some precious time left
before climate change moves irreversibly
beyond man's control if so what are the
most urgent actions to be made in the
years to come ladies and gentlemen it is
a true honor to give the floor to former
US vice president and Nobel Peace Prize
laureates Mr Al Gore please join me
[Applause]
thank you
thank you thank you so much it's such an
honor to be with you and an honor to be
invited to return here to this city and
to give this address to the Nobel Peace
Prize forum
I want to thank Olaf nee Olstad the
Nobel Institute director Servine
Stirling the rector of the University of
Oslo Raymond Johansen the governing
mayor of Oslo leave a tortoise of the
Nobel Institute a Peace Center and I
wish to acknowledge as a group the
members of the Norwegian Nobel Committee
and I wish to congratulate the committee
on their wise choice that led to
yesterday's inspiring ceremony it was a
magnificent statement that the world
must not only recognized but accept
global responsibility for ending sexual
violence and sexual violence as an
instrument of war
Nadia Murad and Denis mukwege II are
such inspiring individuals these issues
must receive not only global attention
but determined follow-up the committee
has played a unique role in focusing the
world's attention on matters of
conscience on matters of security on
matters that affect the human future for
many years until the change was made in
1990 the ceremony took place in this
magnificent hall but as the prominence
of the committee's judgment and the
significance of the award grew over the
years that naturally the audience grew
and it was moved in to City Hall I
remember so vividly 11 years ago it was
the greatest honor of my life of course
to receive the award in tandem with the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change some members of the IPCC are here
and I very much look forward to the
discussion of the distinguished panel
after these remarks and then I look
forward to joining a whole tour for an
interview on stage after that in 2007 I
returned from Oslo I went to Bali for
the climate negotiations that were then
underway and tonight I will leave for
kata Vijay where the negotiations for
this year's conference of the parties
are underway but when I finally returned
back to my home in Tennessee where I
live in the city of Nashville but spend
a great deal of time on my farm 50 miles
away in the small town of Carthage where
I grew up it has only 2,000 people but
it was very proud in 1945 when one of
its residents its most distinguished
resident Cordell Hall received the Nobel
Peace Prize and was described by
President Franklin Delano Roosevelt as
the father of the United Nations he was
the author of the general agreement on
trade and tariffs he sponsored the
constitutional amendment creating an
income tax in the u.s. in the early part
of the 20th century and the small
newspaper that serves the 2,000 people
of Carthage Tennessee put my the honor I
had received here in Oslo in perspective
for me with the headline on the front
page that said
Gore wins same prize Hall won and I want
to say one more word about the IPCC it
was just insulted really by the
governments of the United States and
Saudi Arabia and Russia because when the
governments were called upon to welcome
the latest report of the IPCC two days
ago those three nations along with
Kuwait refused to do so and because the
body that governs the climate
negotiations operates by consensus they
were not able to welcome the report it
was for the three largest producers of
petroleum on the planet to choose a word
inconvenient to welcome the actual
scientific facts so I thought this might
be an appropriate occasion to take stock
of the big changes that have occurred
over these last 11 years the first
change is that the crisis the climate
crisis is growing worse rapidly and it
is growing worse more rapidly than the
world is developing and implementing
solutions we have what can only be
described
as a global emergency the phrase
all-hands-on-deck applies every nation
every business every city and regional
government every civic organization
should be mobilizing urgently to
radically reduce the emissions of
manmade heat-trapping global warming
pollution I will turn to the good news
in a moment a preview is that the second
big change has been the surprising
emergence of solutions that are
available but I want to spend a few more
moments on the fact that it the crisis
is growing worse outside of the door to
this building there is a demonstration
of what one ton of co2 looks like we all
saw it coming into the building
imagine 110 million of those tons being
released into the atmosphere every 24
hours you don't have to imagine that is
what we are doing that is what we will
do again today and there is a common
misperception of the true nature of the
sky into which these 110 million tons
our daily spewed it is not the vast and
limitless expanse that appears to our
eyes as we stand on the ground and look
up at it and wonder it is in fact a very
thin shell of atmosphere surrounding the
plannin the late Carl Sagan used to say
if you had a large globe with a coat of
varnish the thickness of that varnish
relative to the globe is equivalent to
the thinness of the atmosphere that
surrounds our planet 110 million tons of
manmade heat trapping global warming
pollution added to that thin shell every
single day day in and day out mounts up
and the molecules stay there for a very
long time
some say a thousand years but they say
that because the mathematics are
complicated and a certain percentage
falls out sooner than that a tiny
percentage stays longer than that but
think of its residence time as a
thousand years the cumulative amount in
the atmosphere today traps as much extra
heat energy in the Earth's system as
would be released by 500,000 Hiroshima
class atomic bombs exploding every day
hard to imagine that amount of energy
it's a big planet on which we live but
that's an extraordinary amount of heat
energy and it is radically changing the
climate balance the water cycle the fate
of living species on this earth the
course of human civilization and
humanity's future as a species the
evidence is very clear and indeed some
of the evidence is being delivered to us
by Mother Nature the scientists have
renewed their warnings in ever more
urgent language in the report that was
not officially welcomed
in Poland the scientists in the United
States have just completed the US
National Climate Assessment the global
carbon project just released its report
on emissions that deliver the disturbing
news that after three years of
stabilized emissions this this year they
reported on the first nine months there
has been a two point seven percent
increase following a 1.6 percent
increase last year but the messages from
Mother Nature may have more impact
ninety-three percent of all that extra
heat energy is going into the oceans and
the oceans are reflecting it back at us
in the form of much stronger and more
destructive cyclonic storms hurricanes
typhoons as well as cyclones all the
same phenomena with different names in
different ocean basins we are seeing
wildfires like the ones in California in
the American West
this year the fire season has increased
by 105 days per year there were fires
here in Scandinavia this year in fact
six of the fires in Sweden were north of
the Arctic Circle there were fires in
many places because the same extra heat
that warms the oceans also warms the
land and tries to land out and as I
mentioned the water cycle is disrupted
because the amount of water vapor that
comes off the oceans increases as the
temperatures of the ocean increase that
water vapor is carried by atmosphere
rivers that are often 30 times larger
than the Mississippi River the largest
in North America and when it comes over
the land and encounters meteorological
conditions that trigger a downpour the
downpours are much larger rain bombs is
the phrase some meteorologists are using
now and they lead to much more
destructive floods and mudslides and the
combination of disruptive changes in the
precipitation patterns punctuated by
longer more severe periods of drought is
disrupting agriculture and disrupting
other important human activities the
increase in temperatures themselves have
an impact this year will be among the
fifth hottest years in history the four
hottest were the last for 17 of the 18
hottest have been in the last 18 years I
was in Finland two weeks ago and during
the extraordinary heat spell in Finland
this summer many people went to the
local grocery stores to lie in the
aisles near the cooling of the dairy
products and the grocers were very kind
to allow them to make camp there each
night I could give many more examples
but the examples that come from
developing countries are ones that
should capture our attention the heat is
now combining with higher humidity which
on a global average has increased five
percent in the last 30 years to create a
eat index or it feels like temperature
that is close to exceed
the boundaries of conditions in which
human beings can live in several
locations in the Middle East and North
Africa the combination of heat and
humidity has already a sonically
exceeded 74 degrees no human being can
live outdoors for more than a few hours
in such conditions and we learned from
the scientists who specialize in these
matters that large areas of the Middle
East and North Africa some parts of
India some parts of China some parts of
Central America may become functionally
uninhabitable the word is worth
repeating uninhabitable when an area
becomes uninhabitable the people who are
living there leave and they seek shelter
elsewhere there are more refugees in the
world today than at any time since the
immediate aftermath of World War two and
there are many causes for the flows of
refugees civil wars and violence the
kind of violence in the Congo that was
discussed earlier and yesterday but it
is abundantly clear that the fastest
growing cause of refugees is the climate
crisis in Syria for example long before
the civil war broke out in Syria and
opened the gates of hell the worst
droughts a climate related drought the
worst droughts in the 900 years of
record-keeping in the eastern
Mediterranean killed 80% of the goats
and other livestock in Syria destroyed
60% of the farm
and drove one-and-a-half million climate
refugees into the cities of Syria
causing the ministers of that country in
conversations reported through the
WikiLeaks mechanism I hate to mention
their name but printed some interesting
information and the Syrian Ministers
said before the Civil War we cannot
handle this all hell is going to break
loose and the civil war started soon
thereafter most of the refugees went to
neighboring countries and they have
borne that burden with dignity and
fortitude but the minor share came to
Europe and contributed along with other
factors to the growing wave of populist
authoritarianism even the drama
unfolding in London this week as a
connection one of the two most powerful
billboards installed by the pro brexit
forces showed an endless line of
refugees obviously from the Middle East
and North Africa heading toward the
borders of Europe and the slogan was the
EU has failed us all in my country and
the elections just passed president
Trump attempted to make a huge issue of
the so-called caravan of migrants from
Central America to the borders of the US
where they sought to request asylum and
in several interviews with these
migrants they said we're fleeing
violence but the story is more
complicated the isthmus of Central
America is perhaps the most vulnerable
geography in the world to the climate
crisis indeed there is an and you
vulnerability climate vulnerability
index and this year number one on the
list is the nation of Honduras number
five out of 140 at 184 nations is
Guatemala the dry corridor that covers
parts of five countries in Central
America is the region from which these
refugees are leaving many of these
families have not had a harvest in over
a year some in two years they're hungry
and the predictions are that many
millions of others will be driven by
these new climate conditions to leave
the lands their ancestors have always
called home the destabilizing impact of
these climate refugees for the stability
of political systems in the world has
not been featured very frequently in the
analyses of the dangers associated with
the climate crisis but they do impose a
threat to global security there are many
other consequences which I won't take
the time to elaborate but studies just
in the last few weeks have highlighted
the growing rate of ice loss in both
Greenland and Antarctica and Antarctica
with areas of East Antarctica long
thought to be safely stable now added to
West Antarctica as a source of sea level
rise we are a coastal species in the
main and the number of cities and
islands and towns and low-lying areas
like the Bangladesh Delta that will
suffer tragedies as a result of sea
level rise
is a long list tropical diseases are
moving and biologists will alert us to
their strong belief that by far the most
serious consequence of the climate
crisis is the loss of biodiversity we
have already seen in the last few
decades the loss of half of all the
animals on this planet not species half
of all the animals gone we now face the
risk of half of all the living species
disappearing by the end of this century
how do we receive that news what sense
of moral responsibility do we feel when
faced with the news that on our watch
those of us alive during this moment
when the hinge of history is swinging
well perhaps if there was an organized
campaign to cast doubt on the truth of
the scientists work we would not have to
even think about shouldering
responsibility that's what's been going
on that's what's going on in Poland
today and this week it is a disgrace and
the judgment of history will be
extremely harsh of course but we can't
wait for history's judgment because we
have urgent business before us all of us
that brings me to the second of these
two big changes in the last 11 years we
have the solutions available it is
actually stunning
to take stock of how quickly the price
of renewable energy has plummeted some
of us were startled when computer chips
came down in price at a rate that no one
could have imagined was possible mobile
telephones flat-screen TVs the list is a
long one and some areas of technology we
now realize follow rules that are
different from those that govern the
Industrial Age things get cheaper and
better quickly and the good news is that
has happened with renewable energy it is
happening now with batteries it has
happened with LED light bulbs the price
has declined 94% just in less than 10
years it's happening with green
buildings it must happen as well with
sustainable forestry and sustainable
agriculture
we must recarbanation we must recognize
that the best technology we know of to
remove co2 from the atmosphere is called
a tree and when that technology is taken
to scale it is called a forest and we
can hope that clever scientists and
technologists and engineers will come up
with new devices that could actually
remove the co2 from the atmosphere with
efficiencies that exceed that of trees
and forests but we can't wait and yet
we're losing one football fields worth
of forests every second worldwide and
the wave of populist authoritarianism
that I referred to earlier has now
spread to Brazil
with feared consequences for the Amazon
in any case we do have solutions
available to us today they can be
implemented they are being implemented
in my country the fastest-growing job is
solar installer those jobs are growing
nine times faster than other jobs in the
US economy in fact the famous coal
museum in Kentucky just installed solar
panels on its roof to save money for its
annual operating budget the second
fastest growing job is wind turbine
technician it seems obvious to me and to
some others that the world is now in the
early stages of a sustainability
revolution based in part on the new
digital tools of the Internet of Things
and machine learning and artificial
intelligence and a host of other
technologies giving executive teams and
business and industry the ability to
handle electrons and atoms and molecules
and cells and genes with the same
precision the IT businesses have
demonstrated in their skill at managing
bits of information and we see these
changes sweeping the global economy we
need a circular economy because in
addition to the two transforming
agriculture and forestry we have to
transform industry with circular supply
loops that reuse waste and it's not
impossible to do all of these are
changes that will benefit humanity in
multiple ways aside from saving our
future we can use it to create
employment at a time when the secular
Akana
needs increased demand investors are
helping to lead the way as well and I
wish to acknowledge the presence in this
audience of English links Todd from the
Norwegian Bank and the presence of a
good many other investors who have
integrated sustainability into their
investment models I hope that the nation
of Norway will recognize what I regard
as the wisdom of the Norwegian Bank in
proposing a 100% divestment from all oil
and gas assets I know it's a difficult
choice but it's a smart financial choice
as well as a moral and ethical choice if
I've interfered in politics it won't be
the first time but at present we see the
danger we hear the messages from Mother
Nature we have the solutions they can be
implemented what's left to discuss
political will we need policies and our
current policies subsidize the burning
of fossil fuels worldwide at a rate 38
times larger than the meager
encouragement for the acceleration of
the sustainability revolution and of
course the fossil fuel companies and the
associated businesses and institutions
that have thrived along with them have a
tremendous amount of political power and
financial power will that determine the
outcome of humanity's future or will the
conscience of humanity have a role to
play
we are seeing the rising generation
demanding a better world we are seeing
tremendous leadership from cities around
the world
Oslo will be the green capital of Europe
next year my congratulations to you mr.
mayor not only a name but with fantastic
leadership Oslo has been providing many
regional governments the state of
California I mentioned earlier has now
committed itself legally to be a zero
carbon economy by 2045 Ireland has just
announced a complete divestment as a
nation of all fossil fuels and there are
many other examples corporations
particularly consumer-facing
corporations in the global economy are
shifting quickly to 100% renewable
energy and making other changes to be a
part of the solution instead of being
part of the problem but time is running
out some changes regrettably have
already occurred that will not be
recoverable but the truly catastrophic
changes that could end human
civilization as we presently know it can
still be avoided those who I most
respect in the scientific community and
you will see some of them in just a
moment agree on that point there are
uncertainties on the downside as well as
on the upside and most of the reports of
the last few decades have turned out in
retrospect to have been far too
conservative compared to the actual
events that have unfolded a global
emergency as I said at the beginning is
exactly what we confront
but I will close by saying as I have in
times past that for those who feel the
temptation to despair remember how many
great challenges have been overcome in
our history at moments when advocates
also felt despair when the odds seemed
piled up high against success look over
the list of awards given here in Oslo
and you will see the names of champions
who had moments when they were certain
they might be failing but who overcame
the obstacles and always remember that
political will is itself a renewable
resource thank you very much thank you
very much
thank you
thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you very much
if we can't be 100% sure of anything
how sure is sure enough
[Music]
scientists tell us that 20,000 years ago
the earth was about to come out of an
ice age it was significantly colder than
it is today
glacial ice up to four kilometers thick
covered much of the northern hemisphere
[Music]
now geologists and climatologists were
not able to go back in time to observe
temperatures or ice sheets directly so
it's reasonable to wonder how they can
be so certain
so here's one thing I'll do these aren't
circles mark scientific or historical
claims if you're viewing this online you
can pause and click a circle to hear
experts explain the evidence behind it
the negative numbers here indicate how
many degrees colder it was in Celsius
than the late 1900s
the temperatures are estimated by
looking at ice drilled out of glaciers
as well as fossils such as shells that
hold clues about the conditions when
they are formed this particular graph
comes from a study that combines a tee
temperature records from different
locations the authors of the study
essentially averaged these proxy
temperatures together weighing them
differently based on location and other
factors note that the true temperature
history may not have been so smooth
short-term variations like this or this
could have occurred but the level of
precision in the underlying charts kind
of blurs the image variations this big
hover are unlikely to have happened
without leaving a mark in the natural
record as for what causes temperature
changes you may have noticed that the
line has been creeping upwards -
scientists understand why
well the Earth's orbit is composed of
many different cycles of different
duration we experience the daily and
yearly cycles in a dramatic way but some
more subtle repetitions occur over tens
of thousands even hundreds of thousands
of years
in the accumulated effect of these
long-term cycles tracks pretty well with
evidence of ice ages but here's where it
gets complicated these orbital changes
didn't directly cause the temperatures
to rise because they didn't cause more
sunlight overall to hit the earth they
did affect the angle of the Sun in a way
that allowed more of it to reach the
poles which caused the glaciers to
retract Danelle ting ice triggered a
chain of events including new sea
currents in an uptake of carbon dioxide
and these secondary factors ultimately
caused the average temperature to rise
it's an elaborate explanation scientists
are pretty confident they know what
happened but even when the world seems
to be in clear view the picture is
always at least a little bit out of
focus obscured distorted uncertainty can
take many forms and it's often hard for
scientists to explain quantify or even
know how close they are to the truth in
many cases like when we look to the
future truth can't be derived through
observation so scientists have to use
creativity to construct a possible
picture of truth then test it sharpen it
Climatologist have built models that
help them predict how different forces
affect each other and impact the Earth's
temperature they grow more certain when
different types of evidence agree and
when their explanations survive scrutiny
from other scientists
[Music]
let's shift gears and look at what
humans were doing since the last ice age
shrinking ice sheets allowed humans to
cross a land bridge between Asia and
North America
sometimes melting glaciers would
collapse causing massive floods or
abrupt sea rise farming would ultimately
lead to the birth of civilization which
spreads slowly across the globe
[Music]
the earliest on Empire rose in Egypt in
3000 BC other empires would follow lots
of history happened through these
centuries territories were settled
conquered re conquered
big discoveries would change the world
but from a quart numbers perspective the
really big changes were about to happen
right about here at the Age of
Enlightenment and the Industrial
Revolution scientific thinking brought
about dramatic improvements in health
and technology our population exploded
some might say we thrived but population
growth combined with the Industrial
Revolution had environmental
consequences the amount of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere began rising
due primarily to the burning of fossil
fuels this dark line indicates that
humans started recording temperatures
using thermometers which are more
reliable than ice cores or fossils one
could argue that scientists were slow to
grow certain of human-caused climate
change some studies warned of the
problem well over a hundred years ago in
1965 the US presidents Science Advisory
Committee issued a major report stating
that carbon dioxide quote will almost
certainly cause significant changes in
the temperature
since then the earth temperature has
been rising looking back at the 20,000
years we just traveled the recent
warming does not resemble past natural
changes the uncertainty we discussed is
very real but there just doesn't seem to
be enough of it to change the picture
even compared to moments when we were
exiting the Ice Age the most rapidly
today's rate of warming is of a
different magnitude for future
projections scientists must rely on
their models and make a number of
assumptions one being human behavior
this scenario by the International Panel
for climate change assumes we make no
new efforts to reduce carbon emissions
whereas this one assumes we make drastic
cuts enough to keep temperature rise to
two degrees above pre-industrial levels
the gap between these scenarios
highlights uncertainty stemming from
human behavior but what about other
types of uncertainty in the science well
the IPCC projections do specify a margin
of error and there are differing
opinions among scientists this study
considered outside the mainstream argues
that the IPCC projections are too high
and should be about 45% less warm which
would be great news if true but it would
hardly nullify the importance of curbing
emissions some have argued that because
of uncertainty in the science we should
hold back on our efforts to fight
climate change in fact here are examples
when prominent figures have pointed to
uncertainty has a reason to defer u.s.
policy perhaps has been an effective
argument in part because certainty is
hard to explain it's tempting to ask
scientists to talk more simply and
forcefully about their findings to
refrain from sharing nuances that might
be used against them but that sounds
like asking them to go against their
training to compensate for our political
failings or shortcomings as science
communicators
and being too dismissive of uncertainty
can play into another type of confusion
one that I personally struggle with
defeatism defeatists mix-up certainty
with inevitability they see the Paris
coal has a hollow aspiration not an
achievable plan in politics has an
obstacle of positive change not a
mechanism to enable it the fetus --ts
confused not depending on technology for
solutions with not believing in it and
the fetus think they're smart enough to
predict how humans will behave but there
isn't a field of science not political
science game theory sociology or
psychology beckon offer us much
certainty at all when it comes to a key
question
what are we gonna do next
[Applause]
what do we do next
climate change is one of those issues
that the more we study it more we
understand the more serious it becomes
the more complex it becomes and the more
interwove n' we see that it becomes with
our lives the seriousness we see around
us every day the consequences of climate
change at this one degree of global
warming already much larger than we
thought they would be even just a few
years ago and for every report that the
Intergovernmental Panel of climb of
climate change delivers and in the other
body for every report the assessment of
vulnerability gets higher we are more
vulnerable to this climate change than
we thought the complexity is highlighted
at this moment by the discussions that
are going on in Katowice in Poland we
already heard Nobel laureate Gore say
what happened when they tried to welcome
the report from the IPCC they are
discussing other issues as well what
will be the global rulebook they are now
discussing the details behind the Paris
agreement and they're making slow
progress and this year's Nobel laureate
Dennison Quay game highlighted the
interwoven mess of the problem yesterday
in his speech when he told us that one
of the things that we are really proud
of here in Norway are growth in electric
vehicles we think we are doing something
good for climate and environment it's
actually exacerbating a completely
different problem we have to see in a
connected way it is easy to despair in
particular when we are told that the
emissions keep rising things are not
happening fast enough it is easy to
think that we cannot solve the climate
problem but solve it we must and that is
what we will now try to do so luckily I
have with me here a very distinguished
panel who will try to answer this
question of what we will do next here we
have professor Katharine Hayhoe of the
she's the director of
climate science center at Texas Tech
University we have director general Jose
Castaneda Silva of the Food and
Agriculture Organization of the UN we
have dr. Tina Salta who is head of
sustainable finance at the Nadia Bank
here knowing and we have professor
Ricardo Winkleman of the Potsdam
Institute for climate impact research my
name is Baron sunset I am a natural
scientist and climate modeler and I am a
research director of the cicero
institute for international climate
research here in oslo I will address my
first question to Professor Winkleman
because first when we have a problem we
start by figuring out what tools we have
a new work at a rather unique
institution it is a climate Research
Institute that it's not just
interdisciplinary but I think you say
trance disciplinary as well so my first
question to you is really do we have
knowledge wise the tools that we need to
solve the problem yeah to me there are
really two parts to this question part
number one is the question do we have
enough knowledge to understand that we
need to act now and we need to act fast
and the answer is yes absolutely we just
saw earlier an impressive account of all
the different impacts that are already
observed that are already experienced by
people around the world the second part
of the question however however is and I
would argue that we need science and
knowledge now more than ever we urgently
need more knowledge and understanding
how we can mitigate how we can adapt and
the simple and plain reason for this is
we are in uncharted territory never have
temperatures risen this fast in the
history of humankind and we just saw in
this movie that the difference between
an ice age and today is warmer
interglacial that's just three to five
degrees three to five degrees
distinguishing an ice age and today it's
a very vast difference and right now
we're facing the same kind of warming in
the other direction but
much much faster rate now why is it so
crucial that we understand these
temperature differences and the impacts
that come along with 1.5 verse two
degrees versus two point five degrees
why does it even matter
well the reason for this is that the
climate system is full of nonlinearities
and Al Gore actually mentioned a few of
them earlier I'm just gonna give you one
example the Antarctic Ice Sheet so an
article is covered by this massive ice
sheet that's worth fifty eight meters of
global sea level rise so really a vast
ice cover but even though it's so
massive it's also very fragile and we
understand icy dynamics better and
better and we also understand that there
are these so-called tipping points these
critical thresholds that can determine
in just a few tens of degrees whether or
not an ice base and my drain into the
ocean and lead to global sea level rise
so it's these kinds of critical
thresholds that we find everywhere in
the climate system so the Antarctic Ice
Sheet is only one of the examples for
tipping elements in the climate system
and really we found that there are
actually a few tipping elements that are
already at risk of transgressing that
critique threshold within this Paris
range of 1.5 to 2 degrees of warming
that makes it very relevant to pose a
question that was posed to the Forum on
social media because we all all got a
lot of questions in advance so thanks to
the audience who sent all those in one
viewer said if we all decided to take
care of the environment with the damage
be reversible or we already doomed or
kind we at least salvage some mother
earth yeah that's a really good very
important question so of course as my
role my role as a scientist is to lay
the cards on the table and yes there are
some climate impacts that might not be
reversible because we have these
particular thresholds in the climate
system but at the same time and I cannot
stress this enough we live in the
Anthropocene so we're in an age now
where humans actually have the power to
change the climate system
but that also means that we should feel
empowered to also reverse some of what
is happening right now and the very good
news is that we actually know how to do
it we know which knob we need to turn we
know what what what we can do in order
to mitigate some of these changes thank
you they'll turn out to professor hey-ho
the climate issue cannot be solved by
someone on behalf of someone else it
concerns us all as a global issue
now beyond being a very distinguished
scientist you are also a very active
communicator and I know that you have
worked to involve groups who have
traditionally maybe not been so involved
in climate change or maybe even been
actively opposed to it so my first
question to you is really how do we work
to get everyone on board with trying to
solve this issue mm-hmm that really is
the question so I'm a climate scientist
also I live in Texas I am active on
social media and so almost every day
sometimes many times a day I have people
telling me that climate isn't changing
that it's cold outside so the planet
can't be warming that it's just a
natural cycle haven't I heard of the ice
ages or my favorite that we scientists
are just doing this for the money
you might think that these comments come
from people only in the United States
but they don't many of them many of them
come from my home country of Canada more
from Australia the UK even here in
Norway there are people who say this and
think this so often we as scientists
think they don't understand we need more
information
as we discussed the other day we need
animated graphics in our reports maybe
that will help but when you look at
public opinion polling even in the
United States
the majority of people agree that
climate is changing that it will affect
the natural environment people who live
in developing countries future
generations but
then you ask will climate change affect
me personally and the majority says no
the most dangerous myth that the largest
number of people have bought into is
that the impacts of climate change are
distant in space and time it only
matters to future generations or to
people are animals who live far away we
believe that if I am NOT an
environmentalist if I'm not somebody who
cares about the polar bears then I'm not
somebody who would care about a change
in climate but the reality is to care
about a changing climate the only thing
we need to be is a human living on this
planet the reason why we care about a
changing climate is because it is as the
military puts it a threat multiplier it
takes all of the issues we already care
about and it exacerbates them it
amplifies them the reason why I care
about a changing climate is because it
isn't fair it disproportionately affects
the poorest and most vulnerable people
in the world there is a direct
connection between the work of the two
laureates this year and a changing
climate as climate changes it
exacerbates civil conflict resource
shortage wars refugee crises and who are
the first to suffer when these events
occur the woman and the children but
there's good news too and that is that
investing in the lives of women and
children is one of the main ways that we
can work to solve this problem because
the second most dangerous myth I think
that we've bought into is that the
solutions do pose an imminent threat to
our way of life we are here today I'm
alive today because of fossil fuels
because of the Industrial Revolution so
while we must be grateful for the
resources the benefits it has brought us
at the same time what we are missing and
what makes us so full of fear is that
vision of a better future we need the
vision of a better future one that is
free of fossil fuels but this still
provides abundant clean energy for all a
healthy economy
a life for ourselves and for others that
is better not worse than it is today we
have a few of these puzzle pieces
already and we've talked about some of
those the fact that where I live wind
and solar energy farms are springing up
all over the fact that pay-as-you-go
solar is going through 11 countries in
sub-saharan Africa providing energy to
people who only had kerosene before we
see these changes but they have not been
assembled into a full picture of the
future and so the secrets are talking to
people who don't think climate change
matters is not to assume that they don't
have the right values and we need to
help them learn or grow the right values
know the secret is to assume to
recognize that they already do have the
right values we just have to connect the
dots between those values and the issue
of a changing climate thank you as a
fellow natural scientist is very
tempting to start asking you the details
in your research but I know that you
spend an extraordinary amount of time
synthesizing this research together with
all the scientists into big reports like
the very recent u.s. national science
assessment Climate Assessment have you
been able to synthesize an answer from
your line of research or from the other
US research how do we solve the climate
issue I am one of the lead authors of
the US National Climate Assessment which
was just released a few weeks ago it
documents how climate is changing how it
is already impacting us today and how we
as humans are already beginning to
respond to those changes but it also
shows very clearly that we are not
responding fast enough as Ricardo
pointed out the changes that we are
seeing today are so much faster than
anything we have seen in the history of
human civilization and far beyond that
so the question really is how can we fix
this problem and the answer is it is not
up to us scientists alone we need
everyone we need planners water managers
architects artists to give us the
creative vision policy experts
politicians leaders we need everyone to
do this for the future of the human race
thank you so I now turn to
there in general the silver food
production is one of those issues that
is critical for us as a society there's
one of the issues that is most affected
by climate change but we also hear that
some of climate changes because of food
production just another example how
things are interwoven of course we can't
stop producing food so we have or the UN
has listed the UN sustainability goals
and they are all in some or most of them
in some sense linked with climate change
so I would like to ask you from your
role how do we deal with the
interconnectedness of climate change
with all these other issues of which you
are working very closely with at least
one well we in fact I did they are
linked indeed from the very beginning
because in 2015 when we agreed with the
sustainable development goals that is an
agenda for sustainable development for
Humanity for all countries we also
agreed with in Paris to fight climate
change so from the very beginning we're
connected
what does Iran achill is that for
example SDG number two is to eradicate
hunger and all forms of malnutrition
that I considered the bees for the law
others if you have a hunger we will not
be sustainable so ironically since then
hunger is going up we have been able to
- numbers of hunger people in the world
since in 1990 when it will achieve
around 1 billion people we pull it down
in 19 2014 below 800 million now it's up
to 821 the last three years it went up
and basically it went up for two things
that are connected conflicts war etc and
Packt of climate change and when Bulls
overlap hmm
like happens in the Sahel or in the dry
corridor in Central America we see a lot
of things getting together to move
people around to intensify the conflict
by the way we in FAO was the word food
problem we addressed all the countries
in conflict village per village twice a
year and we provide those numbers to the
Security Council Security Council uses
proxy of conflict number of hundred
people food insecurities connected link
it mathematically to war to conflict
when you intensify the word conflict
hunger is there and increasing for the
future what we see this more and more
the role of the climate change promoting
conflict
this will increase food insecurity in
the world
basically for three reasons one is that
we will not be able to produce enough
for the growing population respect will
not be able to produce enough food for
them youth will be dropping even in
irrigated areas we are expecting all
cereals to be affected with low level of
production and erratic production also
due to the draws and floods that
alternated but also because the food
produced it will be less nutritious it
is proven now that with the level of
co2 that we have the wheat has last
proteins less minerals like zinc for
example the vitamin A that is vital for
us so nutrition will be
crazy there is an estimation from the
word bank that the nutrition among
children below 5 that's crucial for the
development of future development of a
child will be 10 20 % less possible so
it's a great impact in future
generations we are destroying future but
also prices will be up estimations we
made shows that price of corn for
example will be up for third percent one
third we will double the price future so
more and more people will not be able to
afford the food they need and let me say
that this brings up I was looking for
the video and amazing you saw that nine
thousand years ago we started to farm II
and we farmers know what that means
mr. Barr so farmer means that you don't
need to do after they go after your food
you don't need to wake up and try to
collect or hunt something to eat that
day you produce it this is what's the
big change of humanity this was the
beginning of civilization now we are
bringing back this in certainty that we
don't know if you have our food
available this is what is the change is
a big change in you for humanity for our
future so correct me if I'm wrong but my
colleagues tell me that about half the
world's food is produced by by family
farms and then the other half is by more
industrial processes and more the bigger
concerns but that also means that a lot
of food is exported or it is an
extremely important commodity will that
be a security issue you think when if
food becomes scarce prices become high
countries or the food producing
countries turn more in on themselves and
and
consolidate what they have rather than
an export this is the question that
we've gotten from some of our viewers
they're all worried about the security
situation for food that could be
attendance that could be a test the same
way that we are rejecting migration we
could started to let's say try to keep
the food for ourselves thinking that
that will solve the problem it will not
solve the problem we need the trade to
provide food for the world trade is a
good thing in providing exchange and be
more efficient in production so but on
the same the other hand where these
we-we-we nowaday we based our food
basically on commodities for products
that are maize soy beans rice and wheat
respond for 80% what we eat around the
world we need to diversify this this is
something that helps to cope with
climate change diversification of
production and more local production of
vegetable fluids that settle help also
because the paradox is we are not only
facing hunger nowadays the epidemic
that's out of control is obesity obesity
is going rapidly so rapidly that we risk
to have more these people than hunger
people in the world by the way if I ask
where in which continent to visit is
going more rapidly I think that I would
not get the any answer for Africa butts
there is in Africa that we have hunger
and obesity growing faster that is Adam
the products that we are eating are not
healthy and climate change has a lot to
do with this thank you so tentativeness
outlets we've touched on scientists we
touch on policymakers we've touched on
the general public we
not yet touched on the global finance
sector to represent which is also of
course crucial for finding the right
solutions and pulling the right
solutions through do you see finance
actors leading the way or does policy
need to lead and then finance follow I
think this is the corporation no doubt
about that and what mr. Gore referred to
earlier today as well we see that now
when the big government's all producing
governments are stepping on the brakes
we see the absolute in the opposite
happening in the financial sector
they're pushing up the climate changes
on the agenda and action now we see that
insurers we see that wealth managers are
actually going together and with the
biggest cooperation we have seen so far
you're actually trying to push
governments to reduce your the use of
coal and also to move hosta to a greener
energy and greener economy so it's very
interesting to see that's working
together even though you are competitors
from the start that you could actually
get something going but it is important
to look at a role from the financials
for the financial sector what are we
doing what are we supposed to do and I
think the most important role for the
financial sector is to put the right
price on on the risk and I think it's a
growing awareness as well that risk
connected to climate changes are growing
it's posing posing a threat to the
financial sector as such and in the
worst place we can end up with a new
crisis a new financial crisis that we
had in 2008 so how do we actually do
that
how do we put a price on the risk which
is connected to climate changes first of
all I think we we should notice that
climate change this is not only the
physical climate changes we're talking
about it's also risk connected words for
example changes in policy that could
come quite fast it could be changes in
regulations
and also very important as well changes
in consumer preferences this could come
overnight and change the way the capital
is flowing very fast so this kind of
risks we have to incorporate in our
models so what's the problem actually by
doing this at the moment I think the
short-term way the financial market is
working we're thinking about Walkley
results we're thinking about half a
year's results annual results but they
don't necessarily pick up the changes we
see in the climate in the society as
such so we need to have a longer horizon
when we measure risk and how should we
do that then I think it's important to
look first of all you have to look at
the taxonomy the way we are referring to
things when you talk about green when
you talk about sustainability when I
talk about green and we're going to talk
about sustainability it has to be the
same thing
otherwise it's confusing it can be green
washing so we need to have a common of
reference of what green and sustainable
is but then we have to have goals old
goals because we need to see the capital
moving faster so far it's a lot of talk
but we haven't really seen the big
changes coming so we need to have goals
we need to have a taxonomy and we also
have to measure the risk and to be able
to do so I also think that we have to
have a more open and clear reporting so
so that actually you can follow up of
what we are doing and we also have to be
more transparent because if you're going
to see where actually we are investing
money how we are managing your money it
could be your pension money it could be
your saving money or it could be the
money for big corporations in there and
investors you need to know what we're
doing so we need we need much more
transparency to see how the capital is
moving and in that kind of sense I think
it's also important to look at how we
could use technology imagine how good it
would be if you have your mobile phone
with an app and if you push that app you
actually see what would be the climate
fit print of your portfolio what could
be the climate perfect prints or for
example one corporation because then you
could easily move your money the money
and the capital yourself so I think this
way of using technology be much more
open and transparent would actually make
it more difficult to hide more difficult
not to move the money in the more
efficient and friendly direction thank
you so Nobel laureate Gore advocated for
a Norwegian clear divestment from fossil
fuel resources do you think that kind of
it's it's kind of it's really a
financial decision but it's also a
simple decision do you think that kind
of a symbol would have an effect
for sure I mean we see the big fonts the
big investors in the world are changing
direction it's exit rent and I think
it's too important to important
happenings that we should mention this
year first of all the CEO of the largest
investment funds in the world the
Blackrock he came out in January this
year and it really was an eye-opener
because what he said was that for us is
not enough any longer just to focus on
the financial return we also need to see
a social return on our investments and
that is a very important signal and also
we saw the CEO of the year of the oil
fund here in Norway or the large
sovereign wealth fund saying almost the
same thing
and of course when you have two big
funds like that setting such a clear
direction you will have the smaller
players coming after as well and of
course there is another risk because
he's saying that actually the cost of
producing solar power wind power is
decreasing very sharply and very fast
soon these energy sources will be
competitive without any subsidies so of
course staying in the fossil fuel for
too long actually could make your
investments not profitable you can
actually lose your money so it's
important to get this shift in time
actually to be profitable in longer term
but also a global climate changes
of course they are global that they are
infecting us and of course government
had to have a per share but we could
also do something ourself I mean we as
banks and financial institutions should
also look at solutions in the small
scale for the local communities to
welcome because the solutions are often
local so how could we actually support
for example solar power in the local
environment women for example that would
help women because it will make their
job easier more easy actually a lot of
the energy were using today as well are
quite polluting so we see we can see
that we could increase the living
standard of people and how Cuba do that
we could have you know green loans for
small communities we can have impact
loans and impact investment for smaller
groups in that way we could try together
also reducing the risk working together
the government institutions because some
kind of risk we don't like in the
financial sector that is political risk
it's also a lot of the technology risk
but if you could share the risk with a
public company or a public fund we could
take some of the risk the public side
could take some of the risk we could
actually generate more money into to
green solutions and capital will move
faster so I think it's a lot of things
we can do here share the word and share
the risk thank you I would like to move
now to the audience poll that has been
rolling can we get that up on the screen
yes thank you so the audience was asked
what is the greatest barrier to climate
action and some options have been
proposed is it the lack of knowledge
about the consequences is it the initial
cost of switching to renewable energy is
it ineffective leadership is it lobbying
from large corporations or is it other
some other issue looking at the results
here I think we have a clear opinion
from the viewers in the audience that
ineffective leadership is something we
have to tackle
part of our leadership is in the
audience so do you look to the poll but
I will post this question now to our
audience I will propose you two
questions at the same time first what do
you think is the greatest barrier to
climate action at the moment and
personally how worried are you about the
future for the earth and for our climate
so let's go back to Professor Winkleman
first maybe starting with your last
question first I am a stubborn optimist
but I'm a stubborn optimist for a reason
so I always listen to the voice of
science the voice of physics and the
voice of reason and within myself and so
I have good reason to be optimistic and
some of those reasons were actually
pointed out by the panel just now we
actually know what the solutions are and
I'm quite surprised I mean 10 years ago
who would have thought that for instance
solar and wind energy would be scalable
as we see it now who would have thought
that electric vehicles which sort of
flood flood the world in the way that
they are doing and so all of those
reasons are good reasons to be
optimistic and so while I think the
climate problem is very severe and calls
for collective action and something that
we all need to work on I think it's
important to also point out that we have
good reason to believe in these
solutions and to be optimistic thank you
well first of all if if you look at
government's I think or leadership I
think it's also a bit of short-termism
within leadership and governments
because often politicians they're
elected for a certain period of time and
the same with boards boards are also
elected often for a certain period of
time and you don't be want sometimes to
be too radical because if you're too
radical you make two large changes maybe
not elected to the next time so in that
kind of way I think this short-term
thinking is not only in the financial
industry but it could also be a
bottleneck within the politics in and
also in the
wardroom and that's why we have to end
that we had to rethink the way we're
actually thinking about climate and risk
but moving on to the second question I
so much happening in the financial
sector now it really gives me hope and
it's also fun to work with because it's
an important sector to actually get a
shift going and it's fun to do this
because we have to set a new direction
we have to close the gap and how to
align our financial business models with
the Paris agreement and with the United
Nations recurrent requirements so I
think you know I'm optimistic that this
is changing and actually see you know
the push coming now from the financial
sector and in that way I hope thank you
doctor I would choose the one of the
orders there because I believe that
they're what we're facing now is the
lacking of funds financial constraint if
you take for example step again on mr.
Gore's the simple things to do is plant
a tree mmm FAO has a project to what we
call great green wall to plant forests
in the borders of the desert more than
20 years that we have this project in
the Sahel and we don't have money is
it's a very simple project we collect
the seeds from the trees that are local
let's survive the border of the desert
we multiply them and then using woman
local we plant the trees we don't have
fun for that project and I can tell you
many stories like that that we don't
have fun to mitigate or to adopt and
it's very costly estimate that
adaptation for agriculture sectors but
include crops animals and forests would
cost basically 7 billion
at least dollars per year and mitigation
would cost four to five times more than
that so talking about 3540 billion
dollars well what we have now the Green
Climate Fund yeah 10 billion dollars in
2015 if we put the money there only
about 6 to 7 and now it has less than 2
billion dollars to finance all
adaptation and mitigation the word that
costs basically at least 50 billion a
year if we don't have the funding we
will not be able to do anything small
farmers are very poor they cannot afford
to adapt they will not survive just that
they will move to the cities and will
complicate even more the problem it
sounds like you're worried very word
because we are seeing this rural urban
migration again back again these people
that's coming from Guatemala
[Music]
most of them that moved to the city
didn't find a way to survive them and
then they are trying to find a way to
survive our less research in Africa
about migration we found that those that
move from the countryside to the city
and cannot find a job what's the
majority move out of the country move to
Europe young people especially if they
are if they can cross the desert of the
Sahara is not the military order to stop
them if we want to stop migration we
need to develop there in their countries
rural development is something that we
forgot to talk about that's what we need
and that needs money
investment is all about debt Thank You
professor hey oh you get the last word
of this panel what is the greatest
barrier to climate action as I said I'm
convinced that the most dangerous myth
that the largest number of people have
bought into is the myth that the impacts
don't pose a threat to us personally but
the solutions do so my answer to the
poll would be yes we lack knowledge part
of the reason we lack knowledge is
consistent lobbying from large
corporations if we lack the knowledge
why would we push our leaders to do
something that we ourselves are not sure
about and why would we have funds if we
have not pushed our leaders to do so all
of these though come down to a simple
issue of very basic and human issue the
issue of fear we're presented with bleak
and dismal almost apocalyptic views of
the future a future where cities are
drowned where sea levels are rising or
extreme heat wipes out entire region's
agriculture but we're also painted a
vision of the future where we return to
the Middle Ages or even worse the stone
Age's with no electricity and no
comfortable lives like we have today so
in terms of my optimism I strive not for
fear but for rational hope we need to
understand the magnitude of the problem
that confronts us but fear holds us back
fear paralyzes us fear causes us to
cling to the past and to resist change
we need to go and look for the hope that
will maintain long-term action that we
need to fix this problem and that hope
already exists but we need that picture
of a better future to strive towards and
that is what will get us going and what
will keep us going as long as we need to
to fix this thank you we have reached
the end of our allotted time on stage I
wish to thank all my co-panelist for
your really excellent insights I
hopefully managed to at least open your
minds to the complexities of the issue
if we didn't manage
find the final solution we also thank of
course Nobel laureate Al Gore for your
excellent introduction and with that we
call an end to this year's Nobel Peace
Prize forum thank you
[Applause]
you